So we were learning how we can use the present to talk about the past using aber, which is to have in sentences like I have gone, I have eaten.
What do you think terminar means?
Terminar.
To terminate.
And uh what what verb would we use more commonly in English
Finish?
Finish.
Terminar is to finish.
Do you remember how to say I have from Aber?
We can look at the two vowels we have in a ber and this will set us off.
Ah yes.
Okay.
So I have
Is it a or a?
It's a good so we have emos.
Good.
How do you spell a?
H E.
H.
E, good.
And that H comes from Aber, that silent H that you have there.
Good.
So how would you say I have finished?
Firstly, how do you make finished?
How do you get the word finished from terminar?
Good.
So you have all the information.
Now you can build a sentence.
I have finished
E terminado.
Good.
And I finished it.
I've finished it.
What is the rule about where this lo la me te can go?
It's in the beginning of the sentence actually, isn't it?
This would be a simplification of the rule that you might find unhelpful.
Well if it was in the two form, it would be at the end.
So after the two form or
Or before everything everything else?
Before the changed verb.
So this is the way we want to think about it.
If we simplify the thought to at the beginning or at the end.
When there's other words there, we might be really confused about where we can put it.
So we must think after the complete verb, the two form, or before the changed verb.
So if you say el lo terminado, you've actually got it after a changed verb.
You've got it after e.
So this is a very rare situation in Spanish where we have two changed verbs together
We see usually after change verb we get a complete verb.
Quiero terminar.
I want to finish.
Puedo terminar.
I can to finish.
Debo terminar.
I must, I owe, to finish.
So here we have to change verbs together.
E terminado.
Weird situation.
Which means there's only one place it can go.
Before the E.
Yes.
It's lo e terminado.
Good.
Lo è terminado.
And I finished them
Los he terminado.
So with R verbs, we take off the R and we put Ado.
With er-ir verbs, we take away the er or the ir and we put ido to get this form of the verb that we need after aber.
Whether it's a ni there's no edo.
No, like I said, there's only one difference between er and ir verbs in all of the Spanish language.
Only one occasion where they're doing things differently, and that was in the present for we.
So for example, we have vender, which means to sell, and how do you say we sell?
Ventemos.
Good.
And we had venir to come, and how do you say we come
Venimos.
So we had emos and emos.
This is the only time in the whole Spanish language that these two verbs are doing something differently.
To get this form of the verb that we need after aber.
Everything goes to ido.
So vender becomes vendido.
Vendido.
And venir becomes
Venido.
Now we understand where is bienvenido from.
Welcome.
Perder, which was to lose, becomes.
Perdido.
Good.
Now we can make some sentences.
How do you say I have lost?
È perdido.
What if you wanted to be emphatic and use the word for I to emphasize?
Yo e perdido.
Good.
Yo è perdido.
And we said that there was a connection between I and we, that we is the plural of I, so this can help us remember
that there is a little connection between e for I have and we have which is emos emos they both use e emos good so how do you say we have lost
Nosotros Nosotros is the word for we for a male or mixed group.
If you are just females, what do you think you might say?
Nosotras.
Good.
You pronounced an S there, which was very good.
Most English speakers find themselves accidentally saying nosotros with a Z.
Not nosotros, but nosotros.
It's an es, nosotros, or nosotras.
So how would you say we have lost?
Emphasizing.
Nosotras, sorry, nosotros hemos perdido.
Nosotros o nosotras, if we all females, hemos perdido.
So we had end emos and then for the rest of the versions we go to the other vowel which was in this word aber
So give me the other versions.
Firstly, he, she, it, you formal have has
Ah so let's start with that one.
How would you say he has lost?
Good, and if you wanted to clarify or emphasize that it was he and not she for example
Elle a perdido, and she
La.
So you must differentiate between she and her.
Don't just let that feminine idea come in your mind and pick one of these.
You must take the time to decide which one is it.
Is it she or is it her?
Ella.
Good.
So she has lost.
Ella ha perdido.
Good.
You have lost informally
As perdido.
Good.
Now, if you want to emphasize, if you want to say you have lost, the word for you for informal is tu.
T U.
Tu
Tu has perdido.
Good.
What was I love you?
Te quiero.
So what is the difference between tu and te?
It's the same as the difference between she and her and he and him.
Only in English we don't have two separate words.
for you and you in those two different positions.
He sees, I see him.
So he sees we use he.
Then I see him, we use him.
This is very intuitive to us in English.
We don't think about it.
She sees, I see her.
Then we have the same change.
But you, it doesn't change.
You see, I see you.
So that might confuse us in Spanish because in English it doesn't change.
But all we need to understand is that tu goes in the group of ella.
Yo tu you and te is in the group of those little words lo la me te so let's practice this what was to see or to view
Ver?
Ver.
And I see is a little bit irregular.
Do you remember how it was?
Ver.
So how would you say I see it, I see him, or I see you formal?
Love.
Good.
I see her or I see it feminine thing or I see you speaking formally to a female.
La veo.
Or how would you say I see them females?
Or I see you plural or females?
Or I see them feminine objects.
Las veo.
Good.
And what if they were masculine or mixed objects or people?
Los veo.
Good.
One set of words.
We have me for me.
We have te for you informal.
We have lo for he for masculine object
U fumel or even for neuter, which kind of just means when something doesn't have gender, maybe you'd say, you know, I want to see it
And that it refers to a situation or something like this, you will use la.
And then from this the other ones come, but building from law.
So you change the O to A to make it feminine and you add your S
for plural.
Which means one sound is left in this little set which is us.
Do you remember how is us?
Nos.
Good.
So this is one set.
Now let's practice the other set.
How do you say he sees?
Is it a V?
Good.
And what if you want to clarify or emphasize
El veh good she sees el good I see
Yo, they.
Good.
Now we said the word for we is nosotros.
Not as.
As is nos.
We is nosotros.
So we see
Nosotros vemos.
Good.
We said the you in fumel was tu.
the U in UC, tu ves.
Which means that we have also the formal U to learn, which is usted, usted
Usted.
Usted, which is the formal lieu.
It's actually a contraction of vuestra merced, which means your honor.
Something like this contracted to usted.
So this is the formal you.
So how would you say you see talking formally?
Usted.
Good.
You see it talking formally.
Lo ve usted.
Or usted lo ve, it can be either way.
The word order in Spanish is much more flexible than in English.
Love usted.
Usted lo ve, either way.
How would you say you see them still talking formally?
Usted ve los.
Sorry, los ve.
Good.
Usted los ve.
So usted is flexible.
Los is not flexible.
Usted los ve, los ve usted.
Now the word for they, the word for they is elos.
E-L-L-O-S and this L-L in most Spanish dialects makes a y sound.
You might hear ellos around Rio de la Plata in Buenos Aires of Argentina, Montevideo, Uruguay.
You might hear like a j kind of sound in Colombia, ellos.
But in the great majority of Spanish speaking world, double L and Y make Y.
Ellos or Elas.
I'm sure you can work out the difference between the two.
What's the difference between ellos and ellos?
Eyos is for males or a mixed group and ellas is for females.
Good.
So how would you say they see emphasizing or clarifying that it's they
Ellos is it then?
Yes.
Ellos then they see then
Eios los ven.
Good.
Or we could have had any combination of gender.
Elas los ven, ellas las ven, ellos las ven, etc.
How would you say they see me?
Eyos me ven.
Good.
Eos me ven.
So we're understanding that we have two separate groups of very important words
The yo, el, ella, ellos, ellas, nosotros, tú, and usted.
Yo veo.
Usted, el, ella, ve.
Ellos o ellas ven, and nosotros vemos.
Then we have the other set of words me lola los las nos te